[Musique]
bonjour maroni et quads prévue
aujourd'hui aux jeunes aux cavs
aujourd'hui mais ça va rencontre une
accueillante familiale à sainte suzanne
elle a proposé des personnes en
situation de handicap ces nouvelles
missions pour les sortir de l'isolément
j'ai hâte d'en savoir plus d'ailleurs
j'y vais alexandre oms étaient en cours
en hockey a très vite si vous aussi vous
souhaitez en saura davantage sur
l'accueil familial domicile si les mois
[Musique]
nous sommes à sainte-suzanne chez
mireille maillot depuis maintenant 16
ans elle accueille à son domicile des
personnes en situation de handicap mais
repart aux activités elle accompagne
dans leur quotidien
cette mission mais rennes la rampe et
grâce à l'agrément du département cet
agrément obtenu en 2005 lui permet de
remplir leur hold famille d'accueil on
va en parler avec elle
bonjour madame maillochaud monsieur ou
accueil chez aux trois personnes en
situation d'handicap
au delà d'un toit passons à pattaya a
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de doute c'est que
le matin même et fils de petit déjeuner
sept médicaments en effet de sortir
menace est avec moi m'a un petit avoir
fait de la cour me demande si tu veux
gagner des demandes que nous fait
quasiment toute rançon comment le
département et accompagnant le
département accompagne cette visite tous
les deux mois si jamais la pagani fait
visible mais ça tu appelles problème si
forte merci beaucoup madame maillot mais
si
les reins fait donc partie de ces
particuliers qui peuvent accueillir chez
eux des personnes en situation de
handicap elle est passée dans cette
mission des agents du département sont
constamment son écoute et la compagne
pour lui permettre d'occuper à 4
possibles à ces ateliers étaient bons
joueurs que tu sais quoi am il accueille
alors ils famille d'accueil c'est une
solution d'hébergement pour des
personnes âgées à partir de 60 ans ou
des personnes en situation de handicap
qui ne veulent ou ne peuvent plus rester
chez elles alors c'est aussi une
alternative à l'hébergement en
établissement d'accord et comment
devient ton âme et d'ajustement alors
pour devenir famille d'accueil pour
envoyer un courrier de motivation à la
cellule d'agrément après il ya une
deuxième étape c'est l'évaluation
sociale l'évaluation psychologique
le passage en commission et si on a une
réponse positive on ne recevra son
arrêté d'agrément à son domicile est
question important quelles sont les
conditions pour devenir famille
d'accueil il ya différentes positions à
avoir mais surtout il faut avoir la
motivation
l'envi d'accueillir une personne âgée
handicapée pour lui apporter beaucoup
d'amour d'affection le partage avec la
vie de famille les conditions
matérielles bien entendu la chambre
voilà de la chambre de la place mais
voilà on va quand même beaucoup évalués
sur l'adhésion de la famille l envie de
partager avec la personne âgée ou la
personne handicapée merci beaucoup ketty
je vous en prie
c'est une relation de confiance qui se
tissent entre les accueillons et le
département une relation à taille
humaine pour permettre à mes rennes et à
d'autres particuliers mais veiller sur
les accueillis en toute petite comment
allez vous ça va bien ça se passe
comment les trois ensembles s'entendent
bien ah oui ce tir trop bien mais ce
distraction c'est la radio et on fait
des sorties actuellement avec zot à huy
peu importe l'endroit me chabat mais
amène aux hôtes avec moi merci beaucoup
de m'avoir reçu madame maillot des samoa
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur l'accueil familial
n'hésitez pas vous avez toutes les
coordonnées qui s'affiche sur votre
écran et voilà le département des
générations est clean si vous souhaitez
revoir cet épisode inspiré des pilotes
précédents mois débouchant nos sites et
non réseaux sociaux quant à moi on
profite très vite pour un nouvel épisode
à bientôt
grâce au chèque marmaille des parents
comme prisca peuvent inscrire leur
enfant à la crèche ou avec une
assistante maternelle depuis 2013 le
département permet aux familles modestes
de faire garder leur marmaille à prix
réduit et vous allez l'entendre le
dispositif est également prévu pour les
enfants porteurs de handicap
[Musique]